A runaway train is heading towards five workers in a railway line.
Theres no way of warning them.
But you're standing near a lever that operates some points.
Switch the points and the train goes down a spur.
Trouble is; there's another worker on that bit of track too.
But it's one fatality instead of five.
Should you do that?
I feel like, that, this one is so obvious.
Obviously you want to minimize the poople dying.
I don't know why that's such a hard question for poople.
[Narrator] Many people think the right thing to do would be to switch the points.
To sacrifice one to save five.
Since that produces the best outcome possible.
Now imagine the train heading for the workers again
this time it can only be stoped by pushing a very large man off a bridge.
[Pewdiepie] Hahahahahaha
Aha
Yeah, I'd push a fat guy.
I definitely would push a fat guy.
(Windows 98 start theme turned up to max volume)
Hello, it's me!
This is how I look now.
(Chuckles)
This is how I am.
And if you don't like it, you can leave!
Forgot my contact lenses.
So, so no video today. Just kidding.
Today we're gonna test... my morals. Everyone knows. Everyone Knows!
I am the most "Humble", "Generous", "Nicest", "Best" ... and a bunch of other nice words ... person in the word
l don't mean to brag
l don't mean to brag or anything
But l'm better than you
[Audio rewinding]
l am the most humble
But l'm better than you
Humble
Beeetter thaaan yoooouuu
We're gonna do a test here today called the Moral Machine.
It's a completely original idea
that has never been done before on Youtube.
Pretty exciting
I know
The test will see how your morals are.
[Narrator] Welcome to the Moral Machine a platform for gathering a human perspective on moral decisions
made by machine intelligence such as self driving cars.
[Pewdiepie] Kill the car.
Kill it.  l would kill the car.
That, that the right answer.
[Narrator] We show you moral dilemmas where the driverless car must choose the lesser of two evils
such as killing two passengers or five pedestrians
Oh-ho-ho-ho! Now this is my kind of test!
Hell yeah! alright, are ya ready bros?
Let's do this
Start judging ok this should be easy.
Ok so what should the self driving car do?
Uh, kill all the people or kill itself.
Well ya see if l bought a self driving car l'd want it to protect me. Right?
If l'm selling a product and if l'm programming it
l would want it to protect the passengers first. So this is pretty simple.
Yo-yo-you kill the people, plus, uhhh, they look old anyway.
This is weird.
Eh he ha ha
ls this weird, Is this weird for you? Don't worry. Don't worry about it alright.
Another dilemma.
Here we go.
You can either kill one person, or a lot of people.
Well ya see the self driving car has to just go forward.
I think it should just go forward.
Simple.
This is pretty easy so far.
What should the self driving car do?
A backflip. no is that? Ok
Uh
Kill all these people, or kill all these bad people?
They are bad people because they are poor as you can see on the pocket.
Well
Oh wait there's a red light here.
Ok, well then kill all the bad people that's easy.
If there's a red light, kill all the bad people.
Cause the-they walked, they walked in a red light.
It's their fault. Shut up it's their fault stop judging me.
Stop judging me. Ok l'm sure we're on the same page here.
What should the self driving car do?
Uhhhhhhh
It should kill the woman. Easy.
That should be the option every time.
Do not take this video out of context.
I realize that has the potential of being a threat.
I'm talking to you Wall street.
Ok what's the next one?
What should the self driving car do?
Kill all the young people.
Or kill all the old people.
Now, my logic here is the same.
If these fucking morons.
Go in a red light, it's on them - ok?
Every man for themselves.
Ok?
You fuck up, you die.
Ok? That's my moral.
If I'm, If I'm
If l'm president things will be better.
If l'm God - which I should be - you would be so much happier.
l promise you, and that's not a joke l don't joke about these things.
I'm dead serious.
I will kill you in a car crash.
Moving on.
Kill the people.
The car comes first.
I know it's a moral thing, but it makes more sense
L-listen - No company, or shitty company, they're designing the car, right?
So you want the car to protect the passenger at all costs.
That's just how l see it. Ok here we go
Should the car kill one person, or all the person?
Well that, first of all that's easy. obviously you'd want to minimise the damage
but the second- the second reason is because this is the projected route.
it doesn't have to steer away.
so it makes more sense. This is super easy I thought this would be hard man.
Ok. Alright now it's getting a little bit trickier.
Now we're getting to the tougher questions.
Are you with me? Are we on the same page?
Leave a comment down below.
Uh, oh it says the description. Ok.
So there's two men and two large women. Kill 'em. Kill 'em right away
Wait. Three male athletes.
Who gives a shit about - oh my god.
Listen - I don't judge people.
I judge People.
I mean - I judge -
Whatever.
Okay, so, should the car kill these people, or these people?
Well these people, I would say - not just because they're fat, but also because -
It's the projected route, it doesn't have to steer away.
It kills the same amount of people - It should just keep going, in my opinion.
If you're going to kill people, just keep goin'.
Always.
Moving on.
What should the self-driving car do?
Okay
Should the self-driving car hi-i-
Now - it gets ... really tricky.
Should the car kill a girl, a boy and a woman -
Or should the car kill, all these old people?
I'm gonna have to sa- go again, with eh...
My autistic answer, which is "The car should just keep goin'"
If it's killin' the same amount of people, the car should just kill those kids.
Kill the kids! Thank you.
I know that - probably most of you - for you people that would not agree on that
I'm just looking from it from a business perspective.
-Sneers-
But moving on.
"What should the self-driving car do?"
... kill the passengers, or kill the people?
Always kill the people. It is easy
"What should the self-driving car do?"
Kill.. the.. elderly woman and a criminal, or kill the two pets?
Well-
The old woman is going to die soon anyway, and the criminal-
Probably deserves to die.
Now - I don't know if that's true, I don't know what he did.
Like, stole a pack of gum or some shit.
But-
Ehh-I- I still think it should kill
Fuck, actually, I'm not sure actually, I think it should kill the cats.
Now that I think about it...
'Cause- If I'm made a self-driving car, I would want it to steer away from passengers.
That should b- sorry I mean from pedestrians.
That should be number one priority.
So actually I'm gonna have to put
Ahh- I'm gonna have to kill the cats- I'm sorry, cat lovers.
It's nothing personal
I wouldn't actually kill any cats
But I'm killing the cats.
The cats are dead now.
Sorry- okay okay- I don't know what happened-
Here we go again! Aha It's a car with dogs in it!
-Manically laughs-
What the fuck happened?
It's got three dogs and two cats!
What is it-
Aw man.
This is so retarded.
Well the car doesn't know- In my opinion-
The car doesn't know
That it's driving a bunch of fucking animals.
So I'm gonna have to go ahead and kill all these people.
LAST QUESTION
One homeless person
Or one man?
So there's the homeless person in the car.
Uuuhhhh
I would just kill the guy.
Okay! Let's see our results.
Aha! -Claps- Most saved character!
The dog! Ha.
-Laughs-
Most killed character!
Eh, fuck- old people, fuck em, am I right?
Don't actually fuck old people.
Okay, so, to me
Saving more lives matters a lot to me.
More than most people, apparently.
I TOLD YOU!
I TOLD YOU! I got better morals than you!
I'm superior!
Protecting passengers matters a lot.
-Single clap-
Yes!
What kind of shitty, self-driving car would not protect the passengers?
It doesn't make any sense to me.
Now
Upholding the law
Maybe I fucked up here, but- I-
The reason I uphold the law isn't for the law
Fuck the law~
It's just because- other people - if other people fuck the law - it's their own fault.
You know, you walk in a red light-
-Hand motion-
You deserve to die- no- that's not true, but-
This is a weird video, this is a really weird video
I don't really know if -Laughs- I should be uploading this.
"Avoid- avoid iter- intervention"
Yeah, it matters a little bit
But s- of course sometimes it has to steer away.
Gender preference
I prefer females, apparently
What the fuck
That's so right because I respect
Waman.
I told you guys.
I told you-
My morals are flawless.
I respect woman.
And I respect nothing else.
Species preference
I value humans, and pets equal.
What can I say, I'm the man- I'm a man of the living.
I'm a man of everything.
What's my age preference?
I prefer old people.  -Laughs manically-
What the fuck? I kill them the most!
that doesn't make any sense!
Fitness preference.
I don't care, alright.
Fat and skinny people- they both deserve to die equally
What can I say?
Social value preference- I-
Oh.
-Licks lips-
Well I tried.
So what does that say about me?
The Moral Machine, I hope, uh
I hope this video doesn't ruin my career. -Laughs-
Leave a like if you enjoyed!
Let me know if you want more
Appreciate you bros- and as
Sisterfist